i want you to help me catch the most
wanted art thief in the world
the bishop
hello boys it's so nice to finally meet
you in person
in this film's about treasure find the
biggest treasure you can i'm curious to
know what is that biggest treasure in
your life that is i guess priceless
priceless i mean i'd be an idiot not to
say
you know um my children i know that
would be the the popular answer but yeah
but you know i have a 10-speed bike when
i was a kid and that
no no my kids i i would do anything for
my kids uh uh
anyone who knows me knows that i will uh
forsake sleep on when i'm traveling
somewhere usually i try to get back same
day so i can put them to bed that kind
of stuff so i i would do just about
anything for my kids how'd you find me
you stole william strang's lady with the
red hat from the tape you can't hurt
that was me
[Music]
i got that on etsy
i'm so excited about this film because
two of my favorite guys you and dwayne
coming together for an adventure and i i
realized that you were the sexiest man
alive before him so now that you've
spent a lot of time with him what makes
him one of the most sexiest man alive
i'm glad you asked me that yeah you know
what makes dwayne the sexiest man alive
honestly it's his vulnerability he has
he has access to a great wellspring of
his own vulnerability and i and i love
that about him i think that's very it's
also a wild juxtaposition from his kind
of persona as this ultra macho kind of
everything sort of big bigger is better
but in you know on the inside he's
incredibly vulnerable and and that's
something i think is really beautiful i
thought you were going to do a joke that
i wasn't no you're right
i've let the team down i realized that
i've completely let the team down um yes
the back of his head does look like a
penis perfect
yeah
[Music]